le combat d'une vie c'est en ces termes
que l'équipe de charlie hebdo évoque la
liberté d'expression cinq ans après la
tuerie du 7 janvier 2015 qui a décimé la
rédaction du journal est choqué la
france entière
charlie choisi de republier les
caricatures du prophète mahomet publiées
pour la première fois en 2006 est à
l'origine de la tacc djihadistes des
frères kwasi un choix courageux pour
certains provocateur pour d'autres cinq
ans après quel est l'état de la liberté
d'expression en france
le 2 septembre dernier charlie hebdo
publie une enquête de l'ifop sur l'état
de l'opinion en matière de liberté
d'expression de blasphème et de
caricature dans ce sondage
59% des sondés considèrent que le
journal a eu raison de publier ces
caricatures au nom de la liberté
d'expression
un chiffre en hausse de 21 points par
rapport à 2006 lors de la première
publication des dessins par charlie
hebdo
moi je pense qu'il faut pas se coucher
je crois que l'esprit de la france c'est
sa part faut pas se coucher
c'est vrai que c'est une tragédie ce qui
est arrivé à charlie mais il faut passer
dévoilement s'est passé ça ne doit
jamais mourir en fait faut pas oublier
en fait on n'a pas le droit en fait
c'est important qu'ils tiennent cette
position après c'est courageux de leur
part
j'aimerais bien que d'autres éditeurs
puissent prendre le relais tête parfois
mercredi il recueillit je continue à
acheter
pas de problème
pour les avocats et proche de charlie
hebdo l'art publication des caricatures
s'inscrit dans le combat de la liberté
d'expression pour les futures
générations
ils se battent et continue à se battre
malgré les menaces malgré le fait qu'ils
n'ont plus de vie qui peuvent plus se
balader avec leurs femmes dans la rue
qui les vivent en résidence surveillée
qu'ils ont été obligés d'abandonner
leurs vies personnelles qui vivent dans
un bunker
il continue à se battre ils ont ce
courage là de les republier il est re
publie pour les autres pour ces jeunes
générations là pour que puisse continuer
à vivre libres
même s'ils ne comprennent pas
l'importance de de la possibilité de
garder son esprit critique y compris à
l'égard des religions mais c'est plus
large que les religions c'est de toute
idéologie à la veille de l'ouverture du
procès des attentats de janvier 2015
emmanuel macron avait défendu depuis le
liban la liberté de blasphémer
je pense qu'un président de la
république en france n'a jamais a
qualifié le choix éditorial d'un
journaliste ou d'une rédaction jamais
parce que la liberté de la presse à
laquelle vous tenez à juste titre
profondément il ya aussi en france une
liberté de blasphémer en france on peut
critiquer des gouvernants un président
blasphémer etc
l'enquète de l'ifop affirme néanmoins
que chez les moins de 25 ans 47% d'entre
eux ne sont pas en accord avec la ligne
éditoriale du journal
autre chiffre marquant 21 % des jeunes
français ne condamne pas explicitement
les auteurs des attentats
des chiffres éloquents qui n'ont pas
tardé à faire réagir l'ancien premier
ministre manuel valls qui se livrent à
une explication politique
quand je vois qu'il y à 20 % de jeunes
qui disent ne pas à condamner les
auteurs de ces attentats
le travail de fond et de pédagogie n'a
pas été suffisamment fait la liberté
d'expression a reculé parce qu'une
partie de la classe politique
une partie de la gauche a reculé d'après
un classement de reporters sans
frontières sur la liberté de la presse
la france se classe seulement en 34e
position en 2020 ces deux places de
perdues en un an pour le pays des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen